You can find any piece of art
that ever existed on Google.
And so that's great.
So,
you know,
when I'm trying to illustrate these,
these lectures,
I type in Abraham Renaissance and then
like I get 200 renaissance paintings.
It's so great.
And then I can look at them.
And one of the other things that's
so remarkable is that all of these,
the major themes of these stories
have been illustrated by people of
spectacular,
my mind,
mind expanding talent.
You know,
there's just this endless array of,
well,
look at that.
I mean,
that's an amazing painting.
And so,
and there's,
and,
and have this,
uh,
there's,
there's dozens of paintings on this
theme and it's just another indication of
how obsessed people,
you know,
this was the only book that existed
for years and people were absolutely
obsessed by it and produced all
these amazing things from it.
And we're in danger of losing that.
And that's a big mistake
because it's magnificent.
A little humility would go a
long way towards restoring it.